[Music]
if et's late-night roundup your quick
catch up on all the most buzz worthy
interviews after dark are their official
talks going on well they're you know
there's some interest and people have
been talking and there's some rumors and
everybody I mean from what I can tell a
lot of people really want the show to
come back so you know it we'll see what
happens
Will and Grace star Megan Mullally
seemed optimistic about doing a revival
of the hit NBC sitcom on Thursdays watch
what happens live I have to assume that
they would have to backup three dump
trucks full of money to get you guys to
do it James Franco was on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert who was a little
concerned over how hard James has been
working I think this is an intervention
we all love you please lock the door
you're not leaving until you drop one of
these projects coming up the ym star
also got candid about being single when
both his brothers are in serious
relationships
there's a saying there that if the
younger brothers or the younger siblings
get married before the oldest married
Wow I know I got like two months Blake
Shelton showed off his romantic side on
Jimmy Kimmel Live
do you take Gwen on like bachelor style
helicopter dates around the Oklahoma
area we actually we use that thing alive
they do gets a lot more use than you
would think does and on The Late Late
Show with James Corden we got the best
holiday gift of them all a holiday
edition carpool karaoke
[Applause]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
you